hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round three of the
OtterBox Norway championship a lot of
you have requested it is dinkler and
versus Fabiano Caruana and since today
it's not res day we do have a bit more
time to cover a few more games and this
is one such game no idea what the
players are doing on the rest day last
year they were having a cooking contest
but this year I'm not sure they probably
mentioned it somewhere but I'm not up to
date if any of you know to comment in
the comment section below so without
further ado let's check it out it's a
really nice game very rare line played
by ding and well it's a very interesting
how Khurana will deal with this very
rare line
ding opens with d4 we have night to have
sex with g3 biting and East 6 Bishop to
g2 Khurana strikes in the center with c5
Knight to f3 and now an early capture
seek after some d4 we have castles by
dink
there's always time to recapture in the
center Queen to c7 and now only knife
captures on d4 and now you don't want to
allow Knight b6 as you could be having
some problems here on the c7 square so
let's just take that square away from
the white knight we have b3 preparing to
finca to the bishop also c4 is an idea
we have d5 by Fabi in the now c4 a nice
pawn sacrifice that has been played
before it's not new D captures on c4 and
now there were some games where Knights
the a3 was played there is a I believe a
few games for Queen to c2 was played as
the Queen on c7 is unguarded but Bishop
to b2 the strongest move recommended by
the engine is it's what's adding place
and you can see that he definitely came
prepared
it's a new move so already from a move 9
we have a completely new game and let's
see how far B deals with it we have C
capture son b3 Fabi accepted the gambit
pawn Queen captures and now Fabi
continuous development Knight to c6 but
the dink has a very firm grasp on the c6
square so he has a very concrete idea
and he goes Knight captures on c6 first
we have B captures on c6 sorry about
that
and the now comes Bishop captures on f6
a move you wouldn't necessarily expect
as this is a beautiful diagonal for the
right dark square bishop but it comes
with like I said a very concrete plan G
captures on f6 is played
and now this is only move 12 and Fabi
already has four pawn islands he still
has the bishop pair so it is some
compensation for the ruined pawn
structure but it's very unpleasant to
play we have Queen TAS III now going
after the c6 pawn as its attacked twice
but also the f6 pawn is under attack
first Fabi defends the c6 point we have
Bishop to d7 and now comes Queen
captures and on f6 going after the h8
rook rook to g8 and the now Knight to c3
ending continuous development we look to
g6 pushing the Queen back Queen to f3
now again putting pressure on this fc6
pawn and now Bishop to e7
and now Fabi wants to play King to f8 to
g8 and somewhat Castle artificially we
could say even though this rook on g6 is
well pretending to be a pawn rook 8 to
c1 with further pressure along the C
file we have King to f8 by Fabi and now
comes night Stewie for this night now
wants to come over to c5 where it will
be a very dangerous piece
Bishop - I ate and now comes Knight to
c5 would a lot of threats here already
Knight captures on e6 wood we knew the
game as you would lose the Queen the f7
point spin so you will not be able to
capture we have Queen to a5 with a
double attack against the night here but
also going for the a 2 point so this is
really impressive play by Fabi his King
is on f8 his pawn structure is all
ruined all across the board but he wants
to capture the a to pawn and then start
pushing his own past a pawn to victory
we have Queen to e3 guarding the night
and now Fabi just captures the pawn
Queen captures na - so fabi's up a pawn
but it's a well really an interesting
position for against three points on the
King side and Fabi has two - passed
pawns on the Queen side so a bit of a
trade-off there and now there are a few
ways you could go about this you could
go Roque one force the Queen to move
tango 93 for the Queen to move even
further back but Bobbie sorry dink has a
different idea first Bishop to e4 with
an attack against the rook we have rook
to g7 and now rook to c2 the first nice
work lift of the game the Queen is under
attack we have
Queen to a5 and now comes Luke to be one
now Dean takes control of the open B
file with Queen to c7 and now comes the
Queen to f3 again putting pressure on
this pawn here and again threatening
Knight captures here which would well
win the Queen King to g8 you don't want
this King on the same file as the Queen
and I looked the b7 attacking the Queen
we have the second very nice rook lift
of the game the Queen is under attack so
Queen to d6 and now Bishop to d3 making
room for the knight on e4
ding wants to further harass the black
Queen
we have Bishop back to d8 and now comes
Knights the e4 as planned
Queen to e5 and now look the c5 we have
the 3rd very nice rook lift of the game
so far me has to decide what to do here
well the Queen and Knight are both
eyeing this f6 squares so you kind of
want to keep an eye on it Queen to
DeForest played and now comes roof to c4
here ding repeats maybe he just wants to
see how Fabi is feeling maybe he wants
to blunder or something but Fabi just
repeats Queen to e5 and ding also
repeats rook to c5 Fabi
also repeats Queen to d4 and now ding of
course is better in this position so
he's not interested in a draw with the
white pieces so Queen to f4 going for
rook to b8 which seems odd as fabi's
rook here isn't really doing all that
much but he's getting ready to support
the advancement of the a pawn so we have
a 5 by 4 by Fabi and now comes Luke to
b8 just preparing to trade here
Luke captures we have Queen captures and
now King to f8 you do want to guard this
Bishop here so this Bishop will now be
able to move and the now comes Knight to
d6 and it's a very dangerous position if
you capture the rook which is the main
idea from ding if Queen captures then
you get cwienke after sandy 8 and
there's no way to defend this Bishop
here you're just dead lost here so after
this night at least six move kink the e7
now with the defense of the bishop here
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to find what being plays here it's a
really nice position and also it will
you know it's a nice opportunity for me
to have a nice sip of my water
for those of you who are able to do is
congratulations as you are an excellent
you know mover of nights and for those
who just want to enjoy the show Knight
captures on the eighth or Knight to c8
check is both fine
Bobby play Knight captures on e8
instantly without even trying to go for
a night to see it but Knight to see it
is there a super interesting move
because after Knight to c8 you have to
go back with the King King to f8 and
then of course you just repeat and then
you capture here but what's the point
you at least give your opponent a chance
the blunder for example after Knight to
c8 check maybe of course Fabi will not
play this but one in a thousand games
maybe maybe your opponent you know plays
something like this not of course in
this level but you know for some of you
who are not on this level you should
always give your opponent as much chance
as you know as you know if there's a
chance for her for your opponent to go
wrong you should give him that chance
here for example if the King goes there
then you will have a very nice meeting
sequence queen b7 check you have to
block captures in c8 and Queen captures
don't see it will be checkmate
so okay of course tink knows that fob is
not gonna go for this but you know maybe
for some of you who are not on this
level you should first try this because
nothing changes the King will still have
to go to have fate and then you're just
gonna repeat but here after King g7 far
being just captures with Queen captures
on c5 and now grabbing the rook and now
Knight captures on g7 so here Fabi is
already down a piece and move 36 but he
does have a passed a pond and the past
seep on his compensation and he's
definitely gonna try and use that with a
four now comes g4 by dink and now a
three so a very dangerous pass one thing
of course wants to prevent it from
reaching its destination we have Queen
to b3 and now Bishop to b6 just honing
in on that f2 square with III blocking
and now Queen to g5 attacking the knight
here and also the pawn on g4 so nice to
h5 giving up the g4 pawn but you do have
to get your knight to safety Queen
captures Knights to g3 and here Bishop
to c5 guarding the pawn here so here if
I be saying okay I'm down a piece but I
have two points for your knight and I'm
not
gonna win this game but I'm really gonna
try so you don't win it either but ding
of course is gonna try with King to g2
na cups h5 would ID ask of pushing age 4
and winning the night here h3 pushing
the Queen back Queen to g5 and our King
to f1 just getting away from that G file
we have Queen to d5 offering a trade of
wincing I can hold this you know with
two points for your knight but ding says
no you can't hear ding can go into
Bishop c4 but he he decides that he has
plenty of resources to go for a full
point here we have C capture some d5 and
now Bishop to be one preventing this
point from reaching the light square and
here ding says okay a 2 is a light
square you have a dark square Bishop
your phone is never crossing the NDA 2
square so far B has to look for play on
the other side of the board we have h4
pushing the knight back nights - E - and
now f5 he has to bring them the King
into the game and somehow hold this with
Knight to f4 biding threatening check
and winning the pawn here so King to f7
now comes Bishop to a2 and rushing back
to e7 Fabi just repeats King to e2 with
Bishop to f6 and the now King to d3 and
here just Bishop to e5
we have Knights the g-tube attacking the
pawn here fiber repeats and now comes
nights the e1 with Bishop to e7 with
King to c2 and now comes King to f6
Knight back to f3 with f4 and now just
Knight captures on h4 with F captures on
e3 f captors on e3 and now King to g5
harassing the knight Knight f3 check
King to f5 and now comes King to d3 so
not allowing the the King to reach this
very nice efore square with Bishop to c5
and now comes Knight the d4 check here
didn't calculate precisely that this M
game would be very much winning for him
after king capture some before as you
have to play something you can't pull
this you're gonna lose this pawn so at
some point your king will have to move
you'll play Bishop here take away the f5
Square from the King and then grab the
e5 square and start gobbling up all the
points so in a very easy and game so
after this night the d4 check we have
king to e5 but now
the f3 check came to f5 and now King
back to e2 we have King to f6 and here
the ship to e1 sorry Bishop to be one
taking the DF 5 and the e5 square from
the black king with E 5 now but now of
course the bishop just goes back Bishop
to e2 and with E 4 and now comes Knight
to d4 so now there are a lot of
weaknesses here and the White King can
approach with King to e5 and now comes
at night the b5 sorry about that Bishop
to e7 and now comes Bishop to b3 with
Russia back to c5 and here h4 starting
to pull the H pawn here we have d 4e
capture Sun before Bishop captures on d4
n are just Knight captures on a3 and
here there is no longer any compensation
here far we played a few more moves with
h5 King to g5 but now Bishop to f7
controlling the past pawn king to f4
Knights the c4 bushra back to g7 but now
rush up to g6 with Bishop to d4 now
Knight to d6 denied is now coming to f7
from where it will control both of the
dark squares which this pawn needs the
cross we have III and now Knight to f7
here we have Bishop to g7 and ding just
play Bishop to d3 and it was in this
position that Fabiano Caruana resigned
the game sorry about that he resigned as
there is nothing to do here the knight
nicely controls both of the dark squares
that the pawn needs the cross to
probably promoted to Queen so here
whatever you play just h6 and you will
have to give up the bishop at some point
Bishop c5 h7 but d4 you will get a queen
and here you will have a knight and
brush up against the King after the pawn
is one of course and of course the Fabia
is not interested in testing dings
ability to win the same way but yes
since we haven't checked the standing so
far here are the standings after round 3
Magnus Carlsen in first place with 5
points as he did score a win here this
was a classical game so the first I went
for cross and in classical time control
then we have with 4 points
dinkler and 11 are none Wesley so with
three and a half points out here mama D
are off with three you yongi two and a
half for Fabiano Caruana two points we
shown at an island and it seems that
Grisha
maxime beaugeois graphic a not had not
yet adjusted to the to the cold Norway
weather sorry about that
still not feeling all that great but
yeah that was the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to think either
kickert Gilbert Baca Dennis Miculek mark
Fenton and Ernest the room for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content most likely
continuing the LT box Norway
championship thank you all I will soon
have an excellent rest of your weekend